good evening everybody it's a real
pleasure for me to be here
um and I'm really excited to tell you a
little bit about one of the technologies
that I think is going to change web 3
but also I think it's just going to
fundamentally change the internet
um so you know this is this is of course
the punch line is in the slide title
zero knowledge cryptography I'm going to
explain the purpose of this talk is to
explain a little bit about what zero
knowledge cryptography is
um and give kind of some you know give a
motivating example kind of trace the
lineage of zero knowledge cryptography
and from its academic Beginnings to its
applications today and then talk a
little bit about some of the use cases
what are those applications and how is
this used okay cool
um oh I made these slides I was just
saying I was just telling someone
earlier I made the slide in markdown
it's on hack MD for those who don't know
hack MD's it's just a little nice little
markdown editor
um if you want to keep the slides for a
few for the future I think they may have
been printed but this QR code is also
you can give you access the size you can
follow along as I talk if you want and I
would encourage you if you have any
questions or comments about the content
any suggestions for other other ideas of
what to include in this deck please
include it here so like hack MD you can
leave comments Etc so
um I spent way too much time when I
originally made the slide deck trying to
figure out how to make it work in hack
MD so I hope someone like participates
on you know leave some comments because
it'll make it all that all that time
worth it instead you know and will make
me feel better about the fact that I did
this instead of do it in Google Slides
which I probably should have done
um
anyway cool so a little bit about me
I as so I I was just uh you know you
guys heard my bio but you know like I
said it's a pleasure for me to be here
and particularly to talk about web3
because I um when I was here at Stanford
I was in in the MBA program and I
started the Stanford blockchain Club so
Stanford blockchain Club I think how
many people are here who are a part of
or have participated in the Stanford
blockchain Club
okay wow so that's
about 20 times more people than showed
up to most of my meetups at the time
um but uh no it's been it's I've been
able to watch it since graduating so I
graduated in Stanford 2019. I've been
able to watch it and meet a lot of
people from the club since then and I
I've been able to see it really grow and
kind of Prosper so I'm really really
excited that that's a community that's
driving here and I'm excited that people
are getting something out of it so
um
yeah and I think it's also maybe maybe I
can also kind of highlight two things
before we get started in the talk how
did I get into web three and then how
did I get into the ZK space so I got
interested in web 3 and cryptocurrencies
actually through my work in the US Army
of all things so like I said I went to
the US Military Academy I studied
nothing to do with computer science or
Tech or anything I studied political
science and Arabic and um
did a number of things while in the
service but my last deployment was
working in uh in Turkey in 2015 2016
training
um Syrian rebels to fight against Isis
and and the Syrian regime and a lot of
folks that I worked with there had been
forced to flee from their homes and were
refugees in in Turkey effectively and
some of them had chosen to volunteer to
fight you know and try and like you know
um you know fight to reclaim their homes
back in Syria but what struck me about
that experience was many of these folks
had played by the rules their whole
lives as they understood them and then
lost everything one day when the rules
changed it's like civil war broke out
battle lines were drawn depending on
what side of the road you lived on kind
of determine whether you could wake up
one morning and find a barrel bomb
falling on your house and your and your
family right so many of these people did
the only logical thing that you could do
which is pick up and flee you know if
you think about if you you know loved
ones you know you of course want to
preserve their lives first and foremost
is pick up and flee them so many of them
packed everything they had drove to the
northern border crossed into turkey
only to find that their life savings
which they'd either accumulated in the
form of like real property or in the
form of Syrian pounds was not not worth
anything when you cross an international
border right either you just didn't have
the real property with you or the Syrian
pounds were not legal tender in Turkey
right and this is something we often
take for granted or at least I did when
I was you know when I first you know
went there and and had this experience
because you know dollars are kind of
like good everywhere right you go
anywhere basically anywhere in the world
and you you can pay in US Dollars and
it's not really an issue but that's not
true for most people most of the time
and particularly in these situations
like Syria like places like Venezuela or
even in Turkey uh in the last few years
where there's been a lot of inflation
like a lot of people don't have that
same strong currency and those same
strong institutions to rely on like we
do here and so I learned about Bitcoin
while they're from a Turk actually and
the idea of a a bank account in your
head that was secured by a private key
or a seed phrase
um you know was what really what really
captured me and what really kind of led
me down this path of pursuing a career
in web3 and crypto by show hands
actually can I get who what's the makeup
of the students in here in terms of like
uh Focus area so first of all is this so
under undergrad Masters can we get like
who's an undergrad
okay who's a master's student
okay who's in who's a non-engineering
student
who is an engineering student okay so we
got like a pretty this is pretty good
mix okay awesome
um so the Stock's gonna be pretty high
level so I hate to disappoint any of you
all of you engineering students but I
highly recommend
um if you're interested in this topic
I'm sure you've already heard this you
know there's many Great Courses here my
you know I'm very biased because the
person I learned this topic from is a CS
Professor uh Dan Bonnet and I highly
recommend his class just don't do what I
did and the first the first CS class I
ever took in my life was cs255
introduction to cryptography so I would
recommend you not start with that but if
you do want to learn more about this
topic and I highly encourage everyone
who's interested in web3 to learn more
about cryptography it's a great course
and you have many grad students so I'm
sure I think I teach that now so anyway
so that's how I found myself in web3 and
was interested in blockchain uh and
actually this is a good segue to talk
speaking about Professor Dan benay I was
in his course as a business student here
and uh he unbeknownst to me happened to
be an advisor to a16z when they were
just starting their crypto fund
um and he sent me an email before class
one one day I think after I'd gotten
like a d or something on a project
because again first computer science
class and a d probably should have been
a f minus given you know there's a
little bit of great inflation probably
was happening there
um but anyway he sent me an email said I
want to talk to you and you know was a
little worried I was going to not be
invited back to class but it turned out
that he you know just wanted to make an
introduction for me for an analyst role
they were hiring for at a16z so the very
Fort the point I want to make it was a
very fortuitous moment for me it changed
the trajectory of my career in my life
and was very fortunate to go to work on
the investing side at a16z I had worked
a little bit before that at coinbase and
and at ggv Capital as was mentioned on
the slide but for me it was really
changed the trajectory of my career was
very privileged to be able to work there
with the amazing folks on the crypto
team at the time there were like seven
of us on the crypto team and now there's
like 700 people or whatever
um but
um as much as I enjoyed that experience
I really wanted to to go to a startup
and have a be an entrepreneur
effectively and I know this is a class
not only about web3 but also about
entrepreneurship so as we go through
this this content I hope to kind of
weave in a little bit of what my
experience has been both being on the
investment side and seeing entrepreneurs
and their struggles to build their
companies but also now being on the
other side being an operator and I did
not start as the CEO of elio which is
the company that I joined after a16z
about two and a half years ago but you
know I have been running it now for the
better part of a year and have I was the
first non-founder employee so I've seen
it Grow from the ground up and I guess
just for everyone for everyone for
everyone's information this talk is not
about a Leo but a Leo does use zero
knowledge cryptography and it was that
fact that inspired me to join it and
it's basically the idea is it's building
and we're building a new layer on
blockchain that uses zero knowledge
cryptography to secure and to scale web3
and we're going to I'm going to talk
about what that means in the context of
zero knowledge cryptography but if
you're interested in that I can talk a
little bit more about it during the Q a
okay with that out of the way
the motivation for this talk so
like I said already uh ZK the shorthand
for zero knowledge cryptography is going
to change the way we interact online
why is that I'm going to talk about it
in a minute but at a high level you can
think of it as being able to prove it's
a technique to prove something without
revealing why it's true
and it's a fundamentally game-changing
Paradigm for the following reason like
imagine playing poker and you're playing
you know if I don't know how many people
here have played poker but you know the
idea is you draw a hand of cards and
depending on you know the makeup of your
hand you can potentially you know
certain hands are better than others and
you can win a bet effectively right so
for anyone who doesn't pay poker I think
that was a terrible explanation but
hopefully you kind of follow me
um and you know to make that game work
at the end of the round of betting you
need to show your hands to your opponent
right they need to be able to verify
your claim that you have a certain hand
of cards right and that's the only way
up to up until we've you know
cryptographers discovered this technique
this is the only way to verify that what
someone was claiming wasn't Factory
right but with the Advent of
zero knowledge cryptography you
basically have the ability to prove that
you have a certain hand of cards not
revealing why it's true it's like it
doesn't have a physical analog but it
has many many applications both in web 3
and web 2.
um okay
giving you with that introduction we
have a short history of ZK and how it
came to be how did cryptographers come
up with this
um so yeah this is not going to start
with a bad dad joke although I do have a
large uh roster of bad dad jokes
um so cryptographers what this this
problem was motivated by
uh I don't want to say laziness but
maybe a little bit of laziness on the
part of uh of theoretical cryptographers
mathematicians who you know constantly
reviewing every each other's work and
they're like okay
you know I I this guy you know Bob down
the hall said he has a proof for you
know some amazing new theorem or
something like that it's like well
it's 25 Pages that's a lot of reading
and you know I want to go I you know I
want to go have a beer I want to go do
something else and so is it do I really
have to read all 25 pages of this to be
convinced that this work is true right
so this is the theoretical foundation
for zero knowledge cryptography was this
concept of of interactive proofs it's
like okay give and this is I gave it a
tangible example but this is motive this
is kind of you know described in in
theory in the papers that have talked
about IP but the idea of Ip is basically
like I have a long transcript and I
don't want to read the whole transcript
for you to you for you to understand
that I know what I'm talking about right
so you imagine two parties so one person
has a claim and then the other party
basically asks questions to the person
with the claim and after a certain
number of rounds that person can be
convinced that the claim is true even
and and the transcript of the
interaction should be shorter than the
statement being proven that's really the
key thing right that's why I kind of
said it was motivated by that laziness
but maybe efficiency right you're like I
want to ask some questions and know
whether you're telling the truth without
necessarily having to read the whole
thing myself I so this is called this is
you know roughly speaking these are what
interactive proofs are so in the
parlance of cryptography we say there's
approver and a verifier approver is
trying to prove a claim the verifier is
asking questions and I'll at the end at
the end of that interaction the verifier
accepts your Rejects
and this it turns out like I don't know
who here is a computer science student
anyone Okay cool so and what's I think
is the cs103 is the theory course right
is that still true Okay cool so you know
it turns out uh interactive proofs apply
to an a gigantic range of problems right
so IP the famous theorem is IP equals P
space for those and and who've taken
cs103 so basically like for anyone who's
not in the Cs curriculum you can
basically convert many many types of
very hard problems into an interactive
proof problem right so it's really it's
a really really interesting result and
it has a lot of applications and so the
tldr for this talk in the context of ZK
is that even though it's it's a slightly
weird way of referent of of Designing
problems or applications you can convert
a lot of applications that we would care
about into this context
okay this slide kind of got a little cut
off which is unfortunate but
um Yep this is something what I already
kind of talked about this is basically
what it is so Alice is the prover Bob is
the verifier so Alice claims something
Bob's gonna ask some questions this
round this repeats over and over and
then the interaction again the key thing
is that the interaction the transcript
of that interaction is shorter than the
claim itself
okay the Key Properties here for
interactive proofs we have completeness
which is that okay every everything I
can make a claim about I can also have I
can also prove in this scheme right and
soundness is that I cannot make any
false claim that is verified correctly
right and then the interesting thing
here and we'll talk about this in a
minute is this is these two claims are
not quite equal you should be complete
like the the proof system should be
complete with a hundred percent
certainty like there's there's
absolutely every statement can be proven
but the soundness is kind of is
probabilistic right so with vanishingly
low probability can anyone generate a
false proof and what cryptographers also
realized
is that you can actually apply this this
idea which has no privacy preserving
properties at all but you can make it
privacy preserving if you apply some
kind of cryptographic Primitives to this
interaction right and this is where the
zero knowledge comes from right so zero
knowledge proofs have a foundation a
fundamental intellectual and academic
basis in this work of interactive proofs
and so this is actually the original
paper where this idea was proposed and
so these are two MIT cryptographers who
ended up winning I think the touring
award
um and this paper was published I
Believe In 1980 but the idea was like
okay we have this kind of interesting
interactive proving protocol what if we
kind of tweak it a little bit in you
know ways that I'm not going to get into
but the I guess the upshot for everyone
here is that let's apply some
cryptography to it to make the
interaction basically hidden and so at
the end of the interaction someone can
come up with a proof without sharing the
transcript and say hey this is correct
this claim is correct
cool
um
this is just kind of more for you know
general interest for anyone who's
curious zero knowledge produced come in
all kinds of flavors and so I'm kind of
I want to trace here the beginning like
the initial kind of ideas and and the
first iteration of zero knowledge proofs
all the way up to what are most commonly
deployed today which are ZK snarks in
their variety of flavors so interactive
proofs plus this zero knowledge property
is called Sigma protocols so this is
this is like kind of the original form
of ZK an interesting Sigma protocol that
maybe some of you have heard of is the
schnor signature scheme so schnor is
used I think now in Bitcoin and in a
couple other protocols
um if you take Sigma protocols and sigma
Protocols are inherently interactive and
you can apply a technique called Fiat
Shamir which is basically like the hand
wave version is like you simulate a
transcript of a verifier asking
questions by just hashing you basically
use a hash function to give like
effectively a random you know you
randomize a verifiers list of questions
right you can simulate the verify with
the hash function effectively and that
gets you non-interactive zero knowledge
arguments and that's what those are
called musics and then if you take
mizzix and apply an emoji no I'm just
kidding you if you take nizzix and you
apply this you know some some kind of
specialized cryptography that really is
all about compressing that interaction
you get aware called ZK snarks and ZK
snarks I think I actually even have the
acronym defined here yes
zero knowledge succinct non-interactive
argument of knowledge
by the way uh there's an amazing
potential roster of web 3 trivia
questions so brainstorm idea for anyone
who's running like a blockchain club
event you can do you can do acronym
trivia uh and just come up with there's
some really amazing acronyms out there
that make no sense at all and this one
is probably one of the more sensical
ones but as you can see it's a mouthful
so let's walk through this one at a time
or one one word at a time so we all
understand what we're talking about here
uh zero knowledge so the zero knowledge
I think we explained succinct is really
important the succinctness here is that
the interaction is smaller than the
actual uh than the actual claim itself
right so whatever computation is being
proven the proof is smaller in size than
that not interactive means that you
don't actually need to have two parties
engaging with each other and then
argument of knowledge is basically just
a claim right so this is a claim that I
know something
okay
um yeah so I mentioned snore protocols
already this is kind of like another
visualization of uh the evolution of
Sigma from Sigma excuse me Sigma
protocols to ZK snarks and on this slide
this might be where you start to
recognize something or some some systems
you may be more familiar with if you're
familiar with web3 right so we kind of
had snore protocol which is a signature
scheme developed in the 90s and pcps are
something called probabilistically
checkable proofs I'm not going to get
into what those are but those were
really the precursors for these various
proof systems and these are all like
these words on the right side here and
the 2010s are all based on basically
titles of papers that proposed various
proof systems uh to use urinology every
every zero knowledge proof system like
all these names here Pinocchio ground 16
Planck Starks Marlin like the way to
think about zero knowledge proves is
they kind of consist of two components
there's a commitment scheme which is
basically like the the part that makes
sure that the prover can't cheat and
there's this interactive Oracle proof
system right which is basically like uh
the means in which the prover and the
verifier are the means in which the
prover answers questions right so those
two things can be combined and in fact
these different Primitives the PCP or
the prime sorry the pawn a polynomial
commitment scheme and the IOP can be
combined in different ways and that's
why you have these kind of different
flavors of proof systems so graph 16 was
one of the first ones that really came
to prominence in its name for
cryptographer Young's Groff who authored
the paper in 2016 and it was first it
was actually popularized by web3 and
specifically zcash which used it I
believe in the Sprout protocol they've
moved on from that to using Halo 2 now
which is also mentioned on the bottom
and these other ones here are some other
kind of flavors of ZK proof systems that
are used in web3 so Starks many of you
have heard have probably heard of
starkware so starkware is founded by
most of the researchers that invented
Starks which are a subset of snarks to
be clear zero note Stark stand for by
the way
okay a succinct transparent argument of
knowledge so again like I said lots of
good acronyms for trivia for bar trivia
Planck and Marlin are two other systems
that are pretty widely deployed
uh okay cool what are they good for so
like I mentioned earlier at the
beginning like what was the motivation
for this before we had this technology
and this technique there's this
fundamental tension between
I know something and
I can verify something right like before
in order for you to verify that I knew
something I had to basically prove it to
you and physically show you what the
thing was right but now with this scheme
and I I this is obviously more abstract
because we're speaking in the digital
sense now I can prove to you that I know
something about revealing why it's true
um kind of just don't trust but verify
and the two applications for this in
web3 which we're going to talk more
about when we get to the use cases here
in a few minutes is they conceal and
they compress information I think I have
some little colors going on here there
we go
um it's important to note that they do
both of these things because in
different web 3 protocols not every web3
protocol that it uses zero knowledge
takes advantage of both of these
properties like for example who who in
this room knows has heard of a ZK
Roll-Up
okay great so ZK Roll-Ups are a form
it's it's a technique for scaling
ethereum uh Layer Two it's a layer two
construction and in that construction
you they don't really use the ZK
property right the the part that
conceals information right the the
application of a ZK snark in that
specific architecture is to compress
computation into a succinct proof that
is is verifiable right so that's like
it's the compression property of snarks
that is desirable in the context of a
roll-up whereas the concealment is more
is more used in places such as like
zcash right so Z cash uses uh the ZK
property of ZK Starks to kind of conceal
who is interacting with who but there's
really no compression that's used in
that protocol so like I said different
web 3 protocols will apply you know kind
of use either of these properties but
not necessarily both
Okay cool so now we're going to talk
about some use cases
um
see
so the first use case and by the way
actually maybe before I get to that
um
I
I'm a huge believer in web3 and
blockchain Technologies but I think that
what we've seen today in terms of the
many many interesting categories that
have kind of come out of web3 so we have
between nfts D5 decentralized gaming
probably 10 other things that I haven't
been paying attention to really at this
point everything has been very
um preliminary and
yeah I think preliminary is the best way
to put it and I would argue that one of
the reasons why the space has not taken
off more than it than it than it has is
because we don't have the ability to
keep information private in the system
if you think about the context of
ethereum for example let's just take an
easy example like who in here has an ens
address okay so if I go to if if I ask
you I won't make you dox yourself here
on the on camera but like if I ask you
for your ens address then we could just
go to etherscan right now type it in it
will resolve to an ethereum address or
an ensn will resolve to any to an
ethereum address and then we can just
see every interaction you've ever had
with that wallet on the ethereum
blockchain like if you think about
comparing that to like how modern
Finance works it's insane it would be as
if like I could just ask anyone for like
you know what's your name and then I
could just find your bank account and
see everyone you've ever paid and
however much you've been paid at any job
and you know what you got your
significant other for their anniversary
or something like that right so I just
wanted to point out that it's like
insane this insane level of transparency
really inhibits a lot of broader use
cases for the technology I think and
this is why I think you see
kind of renewed constantly renewing
interest in this concept of like
blockchain but not Bitcoin blockchain
without the cryptocurrency private
blockchains right one prominent project
which spectacularly failed actually did
you guys talk to the Mr protocol guys so
they come in Evan so yeah so Evan's
probably more qualified than me to talk
about this but Libro was kind of like
one of these things right we're like oh
we'll have like a kind of a blockchain
without the currency I mean that was a
weird situation but this this was kind
of motivated by this idea where it's
like hey for this to be really practical
on a wide scale we need to be able to
give users the ability to conceal some
level of information from at least some
people in the system right because
otherwise a real real I would posit real
economic use cases be it in the nft
space or D5 or whatever are really not
possible so with that in mind let's look
at some use cases for uh ZK one of the
most obvious ones I think is regulated
stable coins
um so yeah like I said the traditional
Financial world is really private by
default payments are obviously a huge
industry that many crypto Protocols are
trying to break into and why why is
crypto even being considered here well
it's because the rails are Universal
right so if you think about Swift you
know it takes it can take days sometimes
for you to settle payments across
borders and so it's very inefficient
very costly lots of money is spent to do
that blockchain solve that problem by
being this this kind of universal
payment rails right obviously things
like ethereum you know you have this
programmability layer you can issue
things like stable coins be they you
know decentralized kind of maker Dow
style stable coins or usdc kind of more
centralized uh you know managed table
coins and the cool thing about using
zkps here is you can just basically
replicate the experience of cash yet
except in a digital sense right so you
can replicate this as terms of like I
can pay you or anybody and like no one
in the system has to know that I did
when if I buy a coffee no one has to
know what kind of you know that I like
pumpkin spice lattes or something you
know and you know it seems like that's a
trivial example but many many companies
like would never submit to having their
contracts become fully public with
suppliers for example right and so
stable coins of course by virtue of the
fact they're stable they're matching to
a existing currency
um you know this is it's a very probably
the most prominent use case in crypto
for payments and you can apply zkps to
really get kind of the nice properties
you get out of cash and as a result
hopefully Empower and create a much
broader um you know kind of economic
activity
um I think we cut off the bottom there
um
yeah
I'm going to come back to the
government's point in a minute so I have
the fourth bullet here is governments
think this is bad I'm going to come back
to this in a minute because I want to
spend I think a whole slide on it
um dark pools or just OT on chain OTC
markets and yeah or you could even
actually think of as regulated icos
um so you don't remember icos I mean
yeah okay some of that no yeah no one
should no way no one who's in the Ico
share your ethereum addresses we'll find
out how much of a Degen you are
um just kidding I've been in my fair
share of d-gen icos so uh full
disclosure but the um you know that like
you could imagine an Ico okay so ico's
got a really bad rap so like okay
everyone's just raising money with
without flatting all the standards but
you can imagine doing an Ico we're like
hey I want to issue some kind of asset
that maybe I know as a security and I
want to make sure the only people that
can buy it are kyc right so this is kind
of this is a use case here we're like
hey I want to make sure I can verify
that users are kyc here and but you know
users are like well do I want to put my
passport data on the blockchain or
inside of an ethereum transaction no so
you can use a zero knowledge proof to
basically gate certain types of
applications here right and and one of
those applications would be like OTC
desks and dark pools and dark pools for
those of you who don't know it's just um
this idea that exists in finance where
you basically have like a bunch of
different uh people who are trading
assets and they don't want to don't
necessarily want to reveal their
identities to each other and they don't
want it to become public knowledge the
type and amount of the Securities
they're selling so they don't like slip
the price or whatever
um cool another very relevant example of
applications for ZK crypto is proof of
solvency so I'm assuming all of you have
heard of FTX I mean you'd have to be
living under a rock to not have heard
about it at this point uh sadly a um you
know someone who I think is probably
maybe people know personally since he
was his parents are obviously professors
here but you know without applying any
personal judgment there and there's many
examples of institutions in crypto and
outside of crypto by the way uh that
fail constantly because they don't
they're insolvent right these are
Financial systems that are fundamentally
insolvent and Dan Bennett actually one
of the first use cases of zero knowledge
proofs that was not necessarily in web 3
for payments was the cryptography lab
here at Stanford came up with this
concept of proof of solvency right so if
you're an exchange or a bank let's say
right you want to be able to prove that
you're solvent without showing everyone
your balance sheet why would you not
want to show them your balance sheet
well because you know depending on the
type of activities you're doing like
people may read into it and they they
decide to sew our favorite acronym fear
uncertainty doubt and then you know to a
large extent like that is what
precipitates bank runs right and then
you are in fact insolvent even if you
weren't to begin with right so this
proof of solvency has been an area that
I think is really ripe to revisit in
crypto in light of the many institutions
that were in solvent last year that
precipitated arguably the biggest bear
Market that that we've seen for the last
few years
um cool
I mentioned a minute ago that there is
this is useful technology not just for
payments and web 3 stuff but also for
web2 so I think actually ZK is already
deployed today believe it or not in some
applications like password managers
right so
um you know in that in that case like
your master password the way it works is
like there's a you know like LastPass
for example you know has this encrypted
database uh online you know in one of
their servers of all your passwords and
then your master password is basically
the you know the key to encrypting it
and you don't actually send that that
that never leaves your device that lives
locally and you just generate a zero
knowledge proof that you know that
master password and that is basically
the mechanism for authenticating to the
server to give you access your encrypted
records which can contain your passwords
and so this is this Paradigm can be
applied all over the place who cares and
why would we care about that well this
is I think one of the most underrated
use cases because the way passwords work
today many of you probably know what's
supposed to happen
is you enter in your password it's
supposed to be hash client-side and then
sent to a database which is supposed to
apply some other techniques like salts
and peppers and stuff when they store
that on a server but the reality is that
often doesn't happen so when they
inevitably get hacked a bunch of
passwords get leaked because they were
stored in the clear or something and
then you're pound right and
fundamentally this will never change
because the asymmetry between the cost
of protecting all this data and
following the correct policies is always
going to be exceeded by the potential
profit from being clever and subverting
those defenses right so there's this
because we are concentrating our data in
this very centralized way there's it's
basically always going to be a huge
honey pot and so the nice thing about
the example I just shared with you where
you know a secret you're proving that
you know it but that the underlying
secret never leaves your possession like
that basically distributes out all these
secrets into each individual client's
hands and therefore there's not really
one single Honeypot to go after so I
think it's actually a fundamentally much
better scheme when you think about it
from a computer security perspective
self-sovereign identity
um so this is another really kind of big
idea that goes just outside Beyond
crypto it's this concept of like you
know we all an identity is kind of
amorphous concept but this is basically
mapping a real world identity to the
digital world
which again has become really relevant
in the current day or in present day in
light of AI right chat GPT
um how many people here have used chat
gbt to write an essay for a class don't
don't raise your hand it's lying as I
almost got you
um but uh you know like kidding aside
right like the amount of content
generated by AI has grown exponentially
just in the last six months and it will
continue to grow exponentially over in
the coming years right and it's going to
become increasingly important for people
to try and identify and understand what
is a bot and and who is a person right
who what is a bond who is a person and
this is you know identity self-sovereign
identity being able to prove your
Humanity in the digital sense be it on a
blockchain or be it on a social media
website is going to be increasingly
important but of course you don't want
to just reveal everything you don't want
to just publish your passport data or in
the case of like healthcare right you
don't want to just like publish all your
personal health information you want to
be able to conceal some of that while
still being able to authenticate
effectively to gain access to some
resource and this is like self-sovereign
identity is kind of a higher order
concept that but I kind of think
authentication is like one small part of
it
um secure voting
this is something that all secure if Dan
were here he would just immediately
stomp out of the room because this is
something that all cryptographers and
security researchers love to bash but I
gave a talk at each Denver which is
linked here so if you guys are curious
you can you can hear it you can read
more in depth on my thoughts on why I
think this can help with secure voting
but fundamentally like you know the idea
of voting at least in a national kind of
political election is you don't want
people to know who you voted for and you
don't want to be able to prove who you
voted for even if you want to right and
without getting into the details which I
which again I said as I mentioned are in
this talk
um the um you know there's there's a lot
of ways to apply zero knowledge
cryptography there to make things more
secure
um cool we're coming close to the end
here we've got the last couple slides
stainless secure like clients and
wallets so this is like um minute
protocol for example uses zero knowledge
proofs again to compress but this is
really nice because what they're
compressing is the state of the whole
blockchain they came up with this really
interesting idea where you can basically
recursively prove all the way back to
the beginning of the Genesis block that
everything that happened up to that
point is correct and then all that a
like client has to hold is a state is a
small 22 kilobyte proof wherein you can
know that the state that you have as as
that's been given to you with that proof
is correct right and this is a really
great primitive tool for building like
Bridges and various more secure like
clients
uh talked about uh Health Data I'm not
maybe I'll talk about the machine
learning but here so you can imagine
applying zero knowledge to machine
learning algorithms right and then you
know either the output that you receive
from the algorithm you can have a proof
that says hey I gave this this algorithm
some data that I'm going to reveal to
you and I got this output right so this
is like probably really relevant for
Health Data and there's a few other ways
to apply it for machine learning as well
I'm going to kind of skip ahead here
because I want to leave a little bit of
time for questions
uh gaming I
said I was going to skip ahead but I do
want to linger on this because I think
this is one of the uh in the long term
this is one of the most important
application areas we're going to see for
zero knowledge cryptography in
blockchain specifically
so blockchains are obviously really
great at D at coordinating just just
distinct groups of people uh towards a
common goal I think you can apply that
to games there's a lot of examples of
blockchain games out there but almost
all of these games rely on either having
some kind of commit reveal scheme in
order to achieve hidden information or
they have a central server I mean most
multiplayer games today use a central
server to basically manage State like I
see this part of the map you see that
part of the map and you know we don't
see each other's Maps right but you can
use zkps to basically replicate what a
central server would do and have hidden
information games on chain and that
opens up a much richer category of games
that you know again because of the by
virtue of the fact that it's a
blockchain and potentially governed by a
doubt players can own players can
determine hey how are the rules going to
change what's the mechanism going to be
going forward how do we incentivize new
people players to join right and so I
think this is a really really exciting
area and the key how does DK fit in here
most of that is related to blockchains
in general in the architecture there but
how does DK relate well you can have
these hidden information aspects of it
which is most games that I think are
popular today
um Dark Forest has anyone played the
game Dark Forest or is familiar with it
okay it's really cool it basically takes
this is again this actually it's again
some MIT students created and it takes
place on ethereum or it's uh hosted on
ethereum I highly recommend everybody
check it out
okay nfts okay great
so now I've hopefully convinced you at
this point that ZK cryptography is the
most magical thing in the world and we
should all you know just cheer for its
adoption and be super excited about you
know all of its magical powers
but I want to make sure that I present
to you kind of the full story here and
and specifically relay some of the
challenges surrounding this technology
like why hasn't it if Alex what you're
saying is so great then why has not the
entire world adopted this technology
what's holding it back
okay so one of the big things
um for those of you who've been
following the space you've probably been
tracking there's a lot of hype and
excitement around what are called ZK
EVMS right so this is you know layer two
solutions that are Roll-Ups effectively
but are are uh programmable and enable
these youth do smart contracts in the
same way that the native layer One evm
lets you right and maybe I guess just
for context for those of you who don't
know kind of the first version of ZK
Roll-Ups just ZK Roll-Ups without the
zkevm you know the idea was like you
couldn't really do a general program you
basically had to hard code whatever the
program was in into the roll-up right so
this is like Stark X for example was
like this
um and there were a couple other
first-gen Roll-Ups that were basically
hard-coded whatever the program was it
could never change ZK EVMS try and
replicate the programmability of
ethereum so you have this you have a
general idea for what program like you
want to deploy on ethereum you just
write some solidity code you know
compiles down to evm byte code you
deploy that on chain and then anybody
can interact with the ZK VM is trying to
do the same thing but
the evm for a variety of reasons
relating to the um The pre-compiled
cryptographic Primitives that you have
access to as developer there is kind of
really incompatible with the
cryptography that's used for efficient
zero knowledge proofs right I'm not
going to get into the specifics of why
that is but it has to do with the types
of elliptic curves that are
fundamentally used and the types of
operations specifically hashing right so
in ethereum uh the kachak hash function
is really used all over the place and it
turns out that that specific hash
function is extremely inefficient to do
inside of the zero knowledge proof there
are other hash functions that are much
more efficient but the kachak function
specifically is just really hard
lack of tooling up until recently I
think maybe the last year if you wanted
to write a program if you wanted to
create a program that leveraged zero
knowledge cryptography say you wanted to
prove like all these use cases I just
mentioned but you want to prove your
identity without revealing you know what
your social security number is
the only way to achieve that was to use
a language called circum which is uh
which was invented by a guy named Jordy
balena who's now polygon but and it's
it's a really amazing tool but the
problem is it's very very low level like
and the way that you know without
getting into the details of like how you
kind of how the ZK proof or how ZK
proofs work under the hood just you can
kind of think of them as like circuits
right they're often referred to as
circuits right and circum was like this
circuit language so you basically were
like you can think of it as like hand
wiring physical circuits to achieve the
output that you want that was that was
if it sounds kind of complicated in low
level it's because it was and it was
really a pain and not very many
developers as you can imagine rushed to
adopt this in the same way that people
wanted to use JavaScript right or
something some some language like that
so the lack of tooling and really the
lack of these domain specific languages
has really hampered the space thankfully
now we have many more examples of domain
specific languages uh for ZK so Leo my
company a Leo has developed one called
Leo Aztec has developed one called nor
and you know there's there's others that
are currently in the work so the tooling
is getting better but still there's a
lot of of tooling missing for developers
who want to get into this space
um the performance overhead
so one thing you should all be thinking
is like wow I can prove that I executed
a program and I don't have to reveal
anything about it you know like what's
the downside why would I ever not do
that well in terms of resources it turns
out that that takes a lot more resources
to do that as as opposed to what's
called native execution or just Pro you
know running the program in the clear
right you have to spend in some cases
many orders of magnitude more resources
to generate the proof than you do to
just run the program and by the way this
this problem applies to a lot of
different Advanced cryptography for
those of you who are interested in or
have heard of things like multi-party
computation and especially fully
homomorphic encryption this is a much
bigger problem there where it's like
even small problems are basically
completely infeasible because of the
overhead now this has gotten much much
better for two reasons one the proof
systems such as the ones I highlighted
here Starks and Planck Etc are getting
much more efficient in terms of how they
take you know your high level logic and
compile it down into a circuit but in
addition to that we're also starting to
get much better hardware and you're
getting people who are developing
algorithms or libraries to take
advantage of existing highly performant
or you know high performance hardware
and apply it to this problem in parallel
for example gpus so gpus are kind of
like well I guess not you know five
years ago everyone was really excited
about gpus for mining Mining ethereum
and also for AI purposes right in Nvidia
particular there's the Cuda library or
the kind of this Cuda
um
ecosystem where you can write kind of
any program you want and run in the gpus
and gpus are very nice because they let
you program a lot of things in parallel
or run a lot of things in parallel which
has some applications for certain parts
of the ZK proof generation process
um so it's getting better but for
example still on mobile phones today if
you want to generate a proof in fact I
was just talking to someone who we're
working with for a Leo for our Mobile
Wallet if you're generating proof on a
phone
still takes on the order of minutes in
some cases depending on the application
right so this is like a lot of overhead
there's a lot of work yet to be done to
continue to kind of optimize things and
kind of shrink them down to make them
perform it
and the last thing is data availability
right so it's we when looking at zero
knowledge proofs for web three uh and if
you actually maybe this is a uh if any
of you decide to go into VC and you want
to hear pitches for aspiring web 3
entrepreneurs one thing that I used to
hear all the time was you know you're
gonna you have this great amazing system
that's going to be hyper scalable it's
going to you know protect everyone's
privacy and secure everything right and
in many cases and you know oh and by the
way the blockchain was only like one
byte big right or something like this
right
um and you know these are Fantastical
claims but one thing that I think is is
we take for granted oftentimes in
blockchains like ethereum is like all of
the data about all of the programs and
all of the state that we care about is
all in the clear right so I mentioned a
second ago that's a huge drawback
but for from a programming perspective
it's actually really nice because you
don't have to reason about what state
the program has access to and what it
doesn't right you can basically just
assume it's like okay everything in here
is just public and you can just run it
run it straight through as if this is
the inside of a real computer right
when you have this private model where
you're dealing with private State you
have to rely on the user to provide the
private state right and so there's it's
a slightly different model for building
applications in web3 and data
availability is what we call this it
becomes really really important not only
for the underlying data that you use to
compute the proof but the proofs
themselves right need to continue to be
hosted in order for you to verify them
which is why like in the case of
Roll-Ups the data availability layer is
the layer one blockchain is ethereum
right and that's where those proofs
those proofs are stored on ethereum such
that anyone can come later and verify
the state transitions took place outside
of ethereum but but they know that proof
is always there and available
okay I'm going to rush through this here
to kind of get to the end so we have
time I think we have
maybe five minutes or so okay cool so we
got about this we're doing pretty good
so we have Matty we'll have a few
minutes for questions here at the very
end
um Okay so
just talked about zero knowledge proofs
as I've gone through in the beginning of
this presentation there's been a huge
amount of development and you know uh
huge advances in the space
over the last 30 years but particularly
in the last 10 really driven forward by
web3 so we have this Cameron explosion
of proof systems and techniques and
optimizations Etc
um all kinds of things really just
driving this technology towards the
mainstream right and so you can this has
all kinds of applications in the many
use cases I highlighted here and it also
has applications and some of these other
you know in combination with some of
these other cryptographic Primitives
which we're not going to talk about but
things like multi-party computation
encryption you can use all these
techniques together in an ensemble to
really get to really achieve kind of
this ideal secure and private uh
computation
um
Okay cool so I'm just gonna like Blaze
through here the last couple of closing
thoughts I have so again why is EK
crypto important if you take nothing
away from this zero knowledge crypto is
important because it lets you prove
something without revealing why it's
true and let someone verify something
without seeing the details
um and I think the one thing I would
leave you with is that's really powerful
but this talk is or this class is web 3
entrepreneurship and we're all here
because web3 is special and why is web3
special well because we have this
principle of decentralization and
actually we don't care about
decentralization web people we care
about is permissionlessness let's go
back to the very beginning when I gave
you the motivating example for why I got
interested in this space is the Syrian
refugee who no longer had access to his
bank account because he was basically
de-platformed by the government because
he was accused not necessarily was but
was accused of being a sympathizer to a
rebel group right and so that system is
not permissionless it's permission right
and you can be de-platformed for many in
some cases even silly reasons in these
cases right and that's one of the
powerful things about blockchains this
is the motivation around behind Bitcoin
was this concept of permissionlessness
so even though ZK is amazingly powerful
and even though it has a ton of
applications outside of the
decentralized role of crypto I think in
the context of crypto it's important to
remember that we can have zero knowledge
but unless we have the permissionless uh
you know unless we have these these
properties that give us this per this
probably this uh this feature of
permissionlessness you know we've kind
of lost the point at the end at the end
of it and so she we just always remember
that
um and yeah I guess that on that kind of
on that note is like you know I've just
emphasized that this is like progress in
terms of Technology but you know
fundamentally this is a question of like
do we use these systems are we going to
allow for a system of digital cash
that's not a technology technological
question that's a social question that's
a political question do we want this to
do we want people to be able to interact
on anonymously do we want people to be
able to keep secrets that no one can
read right
um you know I think
we've come a very long way as a species
in terms of getting and protecting
individual rights but that progress
isn't always guaranteed and so I would
just encourage everyone who's thinking
about this and in the space to remember
that
and this is the last slide
um ZK is really high right now in terms
of like the web 3 world like everybody
and their mother is doing is deploying a
new ZK protocol some are legitimate some
are not but nonetheless like this is I
think it's finally getting the
recognition that it really deserves as
being a very special technology that can
solve a lot of potential issues not just
with web 3 but with web 2. so with that
um I've got some resources here if you
took a if um if you missed the talk and
you want to keep this for your reference
this is the the QR code for the talk the
resources of the last slide and thank
you all very much for having me
thank you
I think we might have time for one maybe
two questions
cool so one all right so I'll uh we'll
do one question and we'll see where we
stand go ahead
hi thank you so much for the talk I have
a question around you talked about the
challenges with proof sizes improve
generation can you give us a few
concrete examples across different
platforms uh let's say for example I'll
do a simple transfer how long will that
proof generation be however for example
I want to deposit or uh into a lending
pool how much proof size would that be
and lastly can you also give us example
a little bit more complex maybe you know
I'm doing it for you know stop swap how
would that you know look like across a
different platform maybe not just for
allele yes thank you thanks for your
question um I don't have a conquer I
don't have concrete numbers for those
last two because there's not really an
example I could point to where you can
deposit into a lending there's no
protocol today that I know of that lets
you do that and so I don't really have a
concrete number for you there but I will
say on the payments one which I do have
a concrete number four
um the longest running deployed zero
knowledge protocol zcash in the
beginning zcash and by the way there's a
difference in proof systems where I'm
just going to talk about in terms of
zero knowledge and ZK snark specifically
the ZK snarks that zcash uses which are
all based on
um on r1cs initially it was gross 16 and
now they use Halo 2. proofs in the
beginning using Pinocchio which was the
first protocol took about 60 seconds to
generate on a relatively performant
laptop and now they are in under you can
do a transfer in under 100 milliseconds
right so you've basically seen you've
gone from a minute to a tenth of a
second effectively
um you've seen kind of a similar
Improvement on other private ZK systems
that do specifically payments but the
thing that I wanted to you know again I
don't have the concrete numbers for the
other two use cases you mentioned but
the important thing to note when in in
terms of the resources that are consumed
and generating proof it's actually
that's not the full story there's a few
different resources you need to consider
and this is by the way what really how
you get to the difference between things
like Starks and ZK snark like
traditional ZK snarks and plonk Etc
right and so the proof generation time
in a traditional ZK snark like gross 16
is linear in the size of the problem so
you have a bigger problem it grows in a
linear fashion the advantage of starks
is that that growth in uh proof proving
time is sublinear I think it's n log n
um so you basically have this sublinear
growth so that's why kind of starks are
nice for these bigger problems from the
proof size now what's the downside of a
stark compared to a stark well the
verifier time and the proof size not
proving time grows logarithmically which
is good but it's still gross right and
the smallest proof size you will ever
get for a stark is on the order of
kilobytes whereas for a traditional ZK
snark like what zcash and a Leo use it's
just it's a it's a hundred bytes or
something like some much smaller more
compact right and so this is these are
kind of like the different trade-offs
that all of these are taking so for
example in zcash you know you can
generate a proof very quickly and the
proofs are small and verifying the proof
is nice but if you want to do let's say
let's imagine we were doing an
application we're running like a machine
like a large language model or something
I mean that would take a very long time
to do inside of is zero knowledge proof
or if you want to do a unit swap trade
right what is a uniswap trade you're
like hey I want to purchase you know I
want to purchase this asset I have this
asset it's two it's you know uniswap is
a bonding curve it's a function that
relates to balances of asset A and B and
so you have to kind of do some logic
around that I mean depending on let's
take ZK evm based on Starks right like
that's still probably a minute
um so we're getting to the point where
it's getting better but it's still a
little bit too long and this is why a
lot of people are really interested in
Asics for zero knowledge produce because
it can make you can take Asics can make
it much more efficient and much more
performant does that answer your
question
how long does it take for allele to
generate a transfer approve uh so Alias
under a second yep yep per transfer and
uh yeah and if you're curious we
actually have some other concrete
numbers for a Leo specifically I can
share with you after class
does anyone else have any questions
go ahead
oh good idea
yeah so privacy is a problem for the
government because it creates a dark
side so uh some protocols uh deal with
this by restricting transfer size like
Aztec I'm just curious what will be
strategy of elio uh yeah so Elio
specifically so I think so one of the
cool things
um actually one of the cool applications
for zero knowledge producing and a
protocol like a Leo specifically is I
talked about stable coins for a minute
right so you have like you know you can
issue a stable coin on Alia it basically
gives you the same Powers the evm does
but in this private setting but the cool
thing about it is just like usdc on
ethereum you can encode whatever
compliance mechanisms that you want
right and so you can say like hey no
transfers over a thousand dollars only
white listed people are allowed to
participate only whitelisted people for
under five thousand dollars and then
maybe everyone else can do 100 right you
can literally dream up any set of rules
that you want and in order to interact
in that system people can just prove
that they fulfill those conditions now
it doesn't solve every problem right you
have to basically be able to know okay
who's on Blacklist and what's that
identity and how does it match so it's
not it's not I don't want to like hand
wave that problem away but the point is
I think this is actually from a
government and Regulatory Compliance
side this is way better than what we
actually have today because if you go to
a bank and you go count the number of
people that the work in the compliance
Department it's enormous in some cases
for some banks 20 percent of all of
their staff work in compliance and why
is there so many people doing that well
because these things aren't even
programmatically handled at the level of
banks most of the time people have to
manually go through transactions to find
where the fraud is to find where the
money laundering is in fact my former
boss Katie Hahn who worked at the doj
and then was a16z like her I think she
always do with pitches when people ask
us questions like what's the biggest
source of money laundering in the world
Banks right it's like it most people
just use Banks right and they figure out
how to subvert the systems that exist in
order to do whatever criminal activities
they're gonna do and in fact if you had
a system that was based on zero
knowledge cryptography by virtue of the
cryptography like you can't generate
like I said these systems are are
complete and sound right you're not
going to be able to generate a false
proof so if you don't fulfill the
criteria you just simply cannot transact
so in that way I actually think banks
and governments should really welcome
this of course there's other aspects of
this too in an Elio we have this concept
of view keys and graph keys right where
I can selectively reveal who I
interacted with without revealing the
contents and I can selectively reveal
each transaction kind of give folks a
window into that so we have a lot of
different tools to help governments and
help developers and end users comply
with the laws that that they fall under
their jurisdiction but fundamentally I
actually think this is a tool to help
improve compliance not subvert it
last question yeah
um yeah hello uh quick question
two quick questions uh number one what
bit security level do you guys targeted
Elio
um you know just in general for all of
these to your knowledge technology that
you're doing that's kind of like a
little bit of the technical question and
more on the business side of things
um why did you decide
um as a team to deploy essentially Elio
as an L1
um you know focus on privacy and perhaps
not you know just build on top of the
ethereum ecosystem and build something
with related Technologies but you know
that works as they get roller perhaps
yep
um so I actually don't have the answer
because it's a subtle answer because of
the allele protocol is many layers deep
and I'm there's security proofs to go
with each level and I don't have the
confidence enough in all of those levels
like those you know how many bits of
security in each of those to give you
the precise answer I will say this it is
uh more than 128 and and it's so it's
not this is a gotcha it's not 24 or
whatever Star Wars ended up being right
so that's like the it is not that
um in fact so we have uh the founders uh
of elio the technical Founders were all
co-authors on the sexy on a white paper
called sexy which was kind of the
technique which describes how to do zero
and computation and uh and you know are
all most of them were co-founders of
zcash as well so I will get you the
exact number but this is a it is a PL it
is 128 bits plus
um and I'll I'll follow up with you on
that now the use case thing on why not
ethereum you can't do this on ethereum
uh you can't you can't achieve privacy
why because in a roll-up for example you
can do ZK at the roll-up level but then
you have to post to the call data all
the before and after state right and
this is so people can reconstruct what
happened and then verify themselves that
this is correct right or and they can
know what the current state is so they
can if they withdraw they know how much
they have right so this is just like by
ver like at least in the roll-up model
there's no way to achieve privacy this
is why like folks like starkware and
polygon there's this concept of l3s so
you can like okay well you go into a
robe and then you can go into another
roll up and then that's private but then
at that point it gets a little bit you
know that you're pretty far from the
ultimate guarantee of the layer one
right so the motivation fact Howard
who's the CTO of elio he originally
wanted to do a layer two roll-up but
because it was really impossible to get
privacy and also because you didn't have
like you don't have the same
cryptographic Primitives that you need
in ethereum to make this for the
performance we decided to go the route
of doing a layer one where we could
build from the ground up a system that
was basically optimized just for this
use case and that's one of the reasons
why gentleman over here asked how long
it took to do how long it takes to do a
transfer on a Leo I mean if we were
doing it on ethereum it would be on the
order of 15 or 20 seconds right polygon
in fact still they run they have these
giant servers that run a bunch of their
star proofs in parallel and even then
relatively simple smart contracts
interaction take on the order of 40 or
50 seconds right and that's because of
the lack of cryptographic Primitives to
make this really efficient
all right uh thank you so much Alex
Roden for coming here and uh giving a
little extra today thank you everyone
yeah